if anything he has been pushed way to
the right by the institution of
Catholics who are against him for being
to what he sees as walk in the Walk of
Jesus that's the Catholics so now that
takes us to the overarching thing of
where are we with religion uh you ask me
am I Catholic I immediately say yes oh
do I go to church every Sunday no uh do
you do what you're supposed to do as a
no but you're a Catholic why I was
raised
Catholic okay the big data point with
this new generation is they were not
raised that way goes to Tom's Point well
then how were they raised or not raised
now you're looking at the schools to do
what was never a school's concern before
when I went to school my teacher wasn't
telling me how to be how not to be if
they didn't like my behavior they called
home and they said your son did this or
did that deal with it
that structure has been taken away why
we got a lot of broken families so the
kids aren't raised in a faith that way
they were a generation ago they have
been introduced to a media culture
social media amplifies okay but it can't
amplify what doesn't
exist where religion is constantly under
attack and the values under which the
religions used to operate are under
attack so why would the kids be into
something that they weren't raised in
that they've only seen the ugly
underbelly of and they exist in a
secular society meaning you can believe
whatever the hell you want to believe as
long as you don't put it anybody else in
a negative way so I am not
concerned by their lack of embrace of
that the problem becomes well then what
do you Embrace okay you don't have to be
Catholic you don't have to be Christian
you don't have to be Muslim you don't
have to be you don't have to be anything
um but what are you now we start to get
into what the real concern is what are
you really about every generation fears
that the next one is soft and broken and
different in this country right our
parents lived in fear of the boob tube
that thing's going to suck out your
brain and now it's us with the phones I
think we're more right than they were
but doesn't matter um so having concerns
about the Next Generation not unusual
but to Patrick's Point policies ways
mechanisms what are you about that's
where we have the problem what are you
encouraging so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right
here